Nghe mùa mời thống mời trụ tiền tụi trức lễ xuyên quy mối lớn tại định giống nhân kinh nghiệm tám mi năm tình lập đảng ở đâu.
Thâm điểm buồn sự kiện là mang ra mắt tên lợi đàn đảo li lục điện, hoa sòn 2 người, đúng mũ tả lệ thống bu khí chính lượng mạnh nhất mà nước này từng trí tạo.
Theo hàng thông tận trung mân trụ tiền cà xe ngà, hoa sòn 1 sử dụng độn kênh lửa sáng, với lượng đẩy gần 2 nghiệm kêu lơ mấy nít hơn.
Chờ phép phòng nhanh hơn và cơ đồng hơn sau bời các thị trợ.
Nếu chân ra nhìn đệnh thích kế này có thể giúp tên lượng mang nhiều đồ đạn hạm nhân,
ra tăng lửa xuyên tụng hệ thống phòng thu tế lợi của mấy và cơ đồng mạnh.
Giờ phân tích cho sàng, xưa kế này thì hiện só thông điểm dành đầy chính lợi của mình nhớn,
cho mở cảnh tình hình ảnh ninh của bật đồng á là tinh tụi phức tạm.
Đồng thời khẳng định càng kết của chữ tiền trong việc dưới chỉ vì thế thành gì đập lập và sá hồ chúng nghĩ,
như tuên bố của chữ tịch kinh trình hơn tại bởi lễ.